Peter you say you fix scripts that are
sick what are some common illnesses of
most scripts 90% of the time it's about
a hero who doesn't have a change or
compelling change the hardest job for a
script writer and actually for a
producer or a direct or anybody involved
in a story is to make a really cool
character that you might think is great
you might have a really cool setting wow
that's neat we're in the South Pacific
you've never seen that before and this
is a cool character but they don't know
how to change him how to take him from
one place to another so time and again
what I do is talk about that point out
this guy isn't changing or if he is
changing it's not believable and and so
when a bad movie is bad often it's
because this hero's change is not there
it's not real it's not compelling and
sometimes you'll have a wonderful
setting and you'll have a wonderful hero
but he just doesn't change correctly
there's a there's a script that I teach
called killing on carnival row by a
great writer named Travis Beacham
blacklist writer couple years ago this
script felled him got him a lot of jobs
now Travis Beacham is is a fabulous
writer but he's not perfect and what I
teach in my in my classes is this writer
got his notoriety by doing a couple of
things wonderfully well he gave us a
world in this movie that's fantastic
fantasy and in fantasy half the job is
creating a real world you've never seen
before an original world like Lord of
the Rings at the game of Thrones but the
other half is to give us compelling
characters who change and we have a
great character in that script but we he
doesn't go through a change that has the
depth or believability that really would
make us want to watch him all the way
through now Travis Beacham is a genius
at what he does but most writers have
strong suits and and suits that aren't
as strong and character change has to be
at the heart of almost every
a movie mush you're making a superhero
movie where the hero doesn't have a
change and other things have to happen
there but so there's a long winded way
of telling you that to change your
character in a story is everything and
that's what I do if it's not there
you